[Music]
friends premiered on NBC nearly 30 years
ago running for 10 seasons in that time
quite a few guest stars actors with
recurring roles and one main cast member
have died here is the full list friends
fans were shocked on October 28th 2023
when news broke that Matthew Perry had
died at the age of 54 the course has yet
to be determined but says after making
of this video he died in an apparent
drowning in his hot tub at his Los
Angeles home he was best known for his
role as channel of beinging the quick
quitted and sarcastic member of the
friends core cast when in doubt Chandler
could always be counted on to deliver a
clever quip can I interest you in a
sarcastic comment over the course of the
show Chandler experienced some of the
best character developments out of all
six of the friends in the beginning he
was the embodiment of a non-committal
Manchild in corporate Hangar by the time
he began his relationship with moniker
at the end of season 4 and into season 5
he showed signs of maturity and
responsibility the two Maran season 7
episode 23 the one with Monica and
Chandler's wedding and welcome a pair of
twins in the series finale the last one
Perry continued his career in television
with prominent roles in Aaron sain
Studio 60 on the Sunset Strip and his
own Revival of The Odd Couple he also
published his best-selling Memoir
friends lovers and the big terrible
thing in which he detailed years of
addiction issues if friends had a
seventh friend or a character most
familiar to even casual viewers beyond
the main six it was Gunther the manager
of the gang's coffee shop Hangout he was
often seen flitting around in the
background at Central Park waiting on
customers and pulling espresso shots
while rocking a tie a loud shirt and
tightly cropped bleached blonde hair on
the occasion that Gunther spoke in one
of his more than 150 appearances it was
to quietly and for lonely Express his
unrequited love for former coworker
Rachel or to deliver a blistering Barb
against her on again off again boyfriend
Ross when's your birthday May 5th why oh
I I I'm just making a list of people's
birthdays oh mine's December yeah
whatever in real life to help pay the
bills between gigs in addition to his
continuing role as Gunther actor James
Michael Tyler worked at a Hollywood
coffee shop called the bgeo pig he told
BuzzFeed in 2014 I was one of their
first Baristas I think I started there
in 1990 or so he appeared on the long
awaited long delayed Friends reunion
special in 2021 but via Zoom because of
health concerns Tyler told today that he
had been diagnosed with Advanced
prostate cancer in 2018 and the disease
had spread to his bones in October 2021
the 59-year-old actor died Jennifer
Aniston who played Rachel wrote in an
Instagram post friends would not have
been the same without you thank you for
the laughter you brought to the show and
to all of our Lives you will be so
missed Rachel's overbearing father Dr
Leonard green may only appear in four
Friends episodes but he casts a huge
Shadow over the show especially Rachel's
character Dr Green was extremely well to
do in his career but quite hands off
with his children and as as a result his
three daughters have become spoiled
brats who have no idea how the world
works at all when we finally meet Gruff
Dr Green in season 2 the one with the
two parties so much about Rachel's
upbringing and current the Roes become
clear we also have some moments of
empathy for Rachel who is desperately
trying to break out of the old entitled
patterns that no longer serve her as a
WABE self-sufficient career woman while
Dr Green was a character we loved to
hate we all could agree with him on one
thing Ross is a jerk and Rachel could do
better actor lebman had a long and
distinguished career across movies
television and the stage that included a
Tony Award for his work in angels in
America leedman passed away in December
of 2019 of ponia complications at the
age of 82 Mr triger was a Gruff No
Nonsense superintendent of the New York
City apartment building in which Monica
Rachel Chandler and Joey resided on
friends and he facted into the plots of
five episodes between 1995 and 2001
probably the most memorable occasion
came in the 1997 installment the one
with the ballroom dancing after catching
Rachel stuffing the trash shoe to making
her cry Mr triger decides to evictor and
moniker from the building leading Joey
to stick up for his friends and agreeing
to be the Super's borro dance practice
partner at a superintendent's ball for
train Mr Trier was a prolific and highly
recognizable character actor Mike hagy
known for his mustache is shakago accent
and his tendency to play workingclass
characters before friends he played a
cable TV station in employee in wayworld
and the best friend in overboard after
friends he appeared in Brooklyn 99
Shameless and in 2022 he was part of the
main cast of HBO's somebody somewhere
the star of that show Bridget Everett
announced on Instagram that hagate had
died on May 5th 2022 writing a beloved
character actor his love of his hometown
of Chicago and his family were the
cornerstones of his life according to
TMZ hagy suffered a negative reaction to
an antibiotic used to treat a leg
infection and he fell into a coma the
actor was 67 years old before Gunther
for a brief moment in friend's history
there was Terry The Surly coffee shop
owner whose tongue was as sharp as his
black coffee while only on screen for
two episodes Terry offered one of the
most cruel descriptions of Phoebe's
music it's so dreadfully mean it somehow
comes all the way back around to funny
she makes me want to put my finger
through my eye into my brain and swirl
it
around it's also courtesy of Terry that
we have one of the show's most memorable
cameos as Chrissy hind from The
Pretenders plays an open mic set at the
cafe eventually Phoebe even teaches her
the chorus of her Infamous Dy Smelly Cat
while actor Max Wright might be better
known for his turn as Mr Tanner on Alf
his mark on friends as Terry is
indelible R passed away at the age of 75
in June 2019 after a long battle with
cancer a key part of Monica's character
Arc finds her chasing her lifelong dream
of being a chef and on her difficult
road down that path she writes a review
of alesandro's Italian restaurant for
the Chelsea reporter the review
absolutely eviscerates The Establishment
to such a degree that its owner
alesandro actually comes to Monica's
apartment to chew her out while there
Monica learns that the reason the food
was so bad was because alesandro doesn't
actually know how to cook also he's not
even Italian he's Lebanese after tasting
Monica's food a begrudging alesandro
invites Monica to be his new head chef
which turns into another huge conflict
as the old head chef was literally
related to everyone else on staff so
their anger turns to her she conco
Shenanigans with Joey to get a new staff
to take her seriously actor Taylor
Negron who memorably brought alesandro
to life was diagnosed with liver cancer
in 2008 and succumbed to the illness in
January 2015 at the age of 57 Ross
Geller's relationships are so
dysfunctional he's on a firstname basis
with his divorce attorney Russell
Russell is constantly disturbed by
Russ's compulsive Behavior but he also
recognized as a cash cow when he sees
One Calling Ross one of his favorite
clients thanks to all the business Ross
got divorced not once but twice in a
year first from Emily walam after saying
Rachel's name at the alar and then later
from Rachel after a blackout drunk
drive-thru overis wedding in Vegas
Russell is the one to give Rachel the
unfortunate news that Ross didn't
actually file the analment papers since
he didn't want to be divorced three
times Russ are you crazy I still your
wife the moment has big consequences for
the entire gang not just Rachel and Russ
played by Ron Glass who was better known
for his roles on Barney Miller and
Firefly Russell was a rare voice of
reason on Friends glass passed away in
November 2016 of undisclosed causes at
the age of 71 friends didn't often go
into dream territory rarely exploring
alternate avenues for the characters or
offering fresh perspectives on the past
and future but thankfully fans do have
the two parts the one that could have
been which dives into an alternate
universe in which Rachel married Barry
Monica never lost all that weight Joey
stayed on at Days of Our Lives Chandler
is an aspiring comedian Ross and Carol
remain unhappily married and then the
biggest first of all Phoebe is an
investment banker who chain smokes
rather than a floopy vegetarian masseuse
with a unique fashion sense it's in
Phoebe's portion of the story that Paul
gleon perhaps best known as vice
principal Vernon from The Breakfast Club
appears as a boss Jack he's concerned
after Phoebe loses millions of dollars
on a bad deal and has a heart attack
Leon passed away in maj 2006 at the age
of 67 after struggling with mesothelioma
and lung cancer complications caused by
his bestus exposure one of the other
narrative tricks that kept things Lively
on friends was the overwhelming number
of celebrity cameos with a-listers often
playing love interest for the gang one
of the rare non-romantic cameos comes
courtesy of Robin Williams and Billy
Crystal as Thomas and Tim in the one
with the Ultimate Fighting Champion
Thomas and Tim make their way onto the
gang's couch in Central Perk and a
particularly busy morning as a
hysterical Thomas tries to figure out
who might be having an affair with his
wife as it turns out the culprit is Tim
himself which unfolds in dialogue that
was improvised by Williams and Crystal
onset according to Screen Rant and you
are no longer my friend we are finish
the gang is in awe and rightfully so
watching these two comedic Masters At
Work heartbreakingly Robin Williams died
by suicide on August 11th 2014 after a
long struggle with a number of physical
and mental health issues he was 63 Ross
Geller famous he had a pet monkey during
the first season of friends Marcel is a
capu shin who starts off sweet but
quickly grows more and more aggressive
as he ages leading to an uncomfortable
adulthood in which he cannot stop
humping everything around him including
Rachel's childhood stuffed animals as
his friends get more and more annoyed
with Marcel's disruptions Russ decides
to let the Bronx suo adopt him but when
he goes to visit he finds out from
Shifty Zoo administrator Dean Lipson
that Marcel has died or has he the
intrig bills when a janitor tells Ross
that Marcel has been shipped out to
California to become an actor in
Hollywood and the zoo wants to keep the
information under WPS and Russ finds out
that Marcel will be starring an outbreak
2 filming locally he's able to say
goodbye to his old friend with his
favorite song in the jungle comedy icon
Fred Willard might only have been on
screen briefly in friends as Lipson but
he brought his characteristic snark to
the role in a way that played perfectly
with Ross's natural suspicion Willard
passed away in May 2020 of a sudden
heart attack at the age of 18 6 never
having retired from acting in season 4
so one with Joey's dirty day Joey lands
another acting gig this time it's a
high-profile one in a movie starring the
legendary chalton hon before he reports
to the set Joey takes Chandler on a
fishing trip and Upon returning falls
asleep while memorizing his lines he
doesn't get to take a shower before
going to work and smells terrible so he
sneaks into the only dressing room
equipped with a shower estons the
seasoned professional discovers Joey
writes off his misbehavior to nerves and
wants him not to cross him again put
some pants on kid so I can kick your
butt an icon of Epic biblical films in
the 1950s hon starred as Moses in the
Ten Commandments and the title character
in Ben her which won him an Academy
Award in the 60s and' 70s he shifted to
headlining big budget dystopian Sci-Fi
movies including the Omega Man Planet of
the Apes and soilent green eston's
family told CNN that the actor died at
home in Beverly Hills on April 5th 2008
at his home not long after entering the
latter stages of Alzheimer's disease hon
was 84 Joey often talked about his large
Italian family and his grandmothers in
particular season five's the one where
Ross Khan flirt introduces one of them
Nani Joey invites her over to see him on
an episode of Law and Order however his
scenes ended up getting cut so he
scrambles to film a fake Law and Order
episode to trick his Nani who reportedly
doesn't know any English other than the
name Sam Waton and enough to e drop on
an embarrassing conversation involving
Russ French actress lylian chovar played
Nani in the years before that appearance
she regularly featured in The Young and
the Restless Days of Our Lives and
Falcon Crest she also hosted and
produced the business cable TV talk show
Hollywood structured after friends
chovar guest start on Ugly Betty Frasier
and Malcolm in the Middle according to
chah's Los Angeles Times obituary the
actor died in June 2008 Four decades
after a breast cancer diagnosis due to
congestive heart disease she was 82 the
same person played two very different
roles in back-to-back seasons of Friends
in the season 6 episode the one with
Rachel's sister Alexis Arquette plays a
customer at Central Park and then in
season 7 the one with Chandler's dad
Arquette returns as a server at the Las
Vegas drag Club where Chandler's
transgender parent performs both
episodes make clear reference to family
and Alexis was part of the prominent
acting arette family along with siblings
Patricia Rosanna and David David was a
fellow friend guest and once husband of
Courtney Co a transwoman Alexis
documented her transition in Alexis
arette she's my brother arat was best
known for small but important parts in
two major '90s movies The Reluctant
Criminal Who unloads a gun at John
troler and Samy L Jackson's Hitman in
pop fiction and the Boy George obsessed
keyboardist and the wedding band in The
Wedding Singer arette died in September
2016 at age 47 due to a bacterial
infection and cardiac event Complicated
by HIV Stan kersch was only on one
episode of friends but it was a very
memorable one that would possibly cause
some controversy if it AED today in the
one with the I factor Monica goes to a
college party and pretends to be 22
instead of her actual age of 26 she
meets a cute guy named Ethan who says
he's a senior and Monica agrees to go
out with him even under her false
pretenses thinking he's in college after
the two sleep together Monica finds out
that Ethan is really a senior in high
school and only 17 to boot making this
not just an ick fat Factor but an actual
crime in some places myi didn't make one
of us a felon in 48 states kers better
known for his long run on the Highlander
television series played Ethan he died
by suicide in January of 2020 at the age
of 51 Iris as Monica's Aunt who shows up
in the season 1 episode the one with all
the poker she is a bit abrasive and
Rough Around the Edges which is probably
why Monica seeks her assistance and
helping her and her friends learn how to
play poker anaris is apparently an old
card shark who's been been playing poker
since early childhood she agrees to help
but is rude impatient and claims to have
hit Tony Randall with a car but that was
just a lesson in bluffing Beverly
Garland played the sketchy Aunt one of
nearly 200 roles in a nearly 60-year
career really no that's bluffing lesson
number one she started off in lowbudget
movies like it conquered the world and
swamp women then portrayed Barbara
Harper Douglas in my three sons one of
the dozens of sitcom Parts in December
2008 the Los Angeles Times reported that
Garland died at her home in the
Hollywood Hills following a long period
of illness Garland was 82 phoe's
adoptive grandmother Francis only
appears in one friend's episode but it's
a very significant one for the most
eccentric friend of the bunch phebs
didn't actually know that she and her
sister had been adopted at all all the
photographs of her father around
francis's house were actually the
placeholder images that came with the
picture frames explaining why Phoebe
insists for the rest of the series that
her grandmother is in Hell thankfully
though before francis's death she guides
Phoebe to her actual father Frank buet
Phoebe also finds out about her brother
Frank Jor which sets up many new
character ARS for the most eccentric of
the friends and her even Stranger Family
like the time she carries her brother
and his much older wife's triplets
Francis was played by audre Linley
iconic for her role as Mrs rer on
Three's Company she died in October of
1997 after a long struggle with leukemia
meaning she never had a chance to see
how her small appearance on the show
would in fact change pop culture to
history sadly too many friends guest
stars have passed away to discuss them
all in full in this video the others
include Gary Collins who played himself
karta Ferrell who played a juron season
6 Joel B who played Todd the Ombre man
Mary P gleon who played Nurse seore
Shelley Burman who played Mr Kaplan heer
Dennis who played Sherman Whitfield
Kelly waym who played Colleen Gretchen
Wier who played Mrs burkat Phil Leeds
who played Mr a
Elena Reed Hall who played the
admissions Woman Richard Ro who played
Bert Danny Dayton who played buddy Doyle
Paxton Whitehead who played Mr walam if
you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
National Suicide Prevention Lifeline by
dialing 988 or by calling 1
1800273 talk